raven simone is fresh into the newlywed
face of her marriage
and i spoke to the happy wife who is
still on cloud nine
i've been married for a month now how's
it been
it's like a hot toddy in winter honey
it's so good
raven simone and social media manager
miranda mayday had a private wedding
ceremony in june
raven surprised her fans with the news
when she posted this pic
captioning it in part i got married to a
woman who
understands me from trigger to joy i am
a very complicated lady
and my babes is she's independent she's
self-sufficient and she challenges me
every day
[Music]
it's been 31 years since raven got her
start on the cosby show and of course
e.t was with her from the very beginning
my real name is
raven how old are you three and a half
what do you want to see when you grow up
i do want to be actress i do want to be
a ballerina i do want to be
dancing i want to know if it's true that
you have never to this day touched your
cosby show money
this is a true statement back in the day
there was a thing called the cleveland
law
and it's so funny the other day i got a
message from my bank and they were like
you need to go to a court to open this
to touch your money
so yes i haven't touched it but it's
also because i can't
well raven's doing just fine without
that cosby money
now she's pairing up with fellow disney
star miranda may
not to be confused with raven's wife
miranda mayday for an epic
ravens home bunk crossover special
airing friday
on the disney channel you know how many
messages i got that were like did you
and raven get married
yeah people thought we got married which
honestly what a way to promote
we should have thought of it one of our
colleagues hit me and she was like i
knew
you guys were uh looking at each other
special i was like wait wait wait
no no this no we're actually just really
really good friends welcome to camp get
you walk up camp kiki what
it was fun as much fun as it was for us
to make i hope it's just as much fun for
people to watch
you